Hey, speaking of protests, there is a very
important report from the Associated Press
which looked at the arrest that took place at and
related to the various protests that we've seen
around the country over the last several months.
And the study found that most of the people
arrested at the protests are not leftist
radicals are not affiliated with an TIFA
to the extent that one can be affiliated with
an TIFA. They are not anarchists or anarchists,
as Donald Trump sometimes says, the way that
Trump and his cronies and many Republicans have
been portraying the small minority of individuals
at protests. I don't call them protesters because
the ones that are arrested, they're not
protesting. They're doing other things.
But let's reset a little bit before we get into
the data. Since the George Floyd and anti police
brutality protests that we've seen. The Trumpy
in Republican line has been dangerous, violent
leftist, socialist, communist, Marxist anarchists
or some combination thereof are wreaking havoc,
destroying things, burning things down.
The left is violent. And this is the future
of Joe Biden's America, even though it's Donald
Trump's America right now. Now, all along, we knew
the protests have been mostly peaceful and there
have been provocateurs. There have been rioters
who were not protesters who are provoking and
rioting and committing crimes. And it is a very,
very small number of people. OK, the Associated
Press looked at the roughly 300 people arrested
at the various protests and found that most of
the people arrested, even though the protests
are happening in cities, are suburban adults who
came into the cities where the protests took place
from the exact suburbs that Donald Trump says
he needs to protect from the urban people,
which often is code for nonwhite people. But
but, of course, there are urban white people
in urban black people, urban Hispanic people, etc.
understand that those are the people coming into
the cities to create chaos, commit some crimes
and getting themselves arrested. Now, of course,
there are people who got arrested from the nearly
300 whose political views, if you were to sit down
with them and do an interview, are left leaning
political views. But there are plenty whose
views are right wing. There are plenty who are
sort of not political and just taking advantage
of a situation to provoke. Most have no
affiliation with any particular group. Some
have preexisting criminal records. Some don't.
Some were illegally carrying weapons at the times
of their arrests. Some were not, but certainly
almost no. You know, this idea of ties to antifa
almost nonexistent. Most no previous criminality,
period. The most common charges against those
arrested are No. One, arson, followed by illegal
possession of a firearm. Just those two crimes are
about 45 percent of all the arrests. And then
you've got some of these vague civil unrest.
Disorderly conduct impeding a federal officer,
some property damage, some failing to obey a
lawful order. And when you look at the list,
lots of these are these sort of B.S. charges
equivalent to resisting arrest. And I'm
certainly including disorderly conduct in that
not obeying a lawful order.
You know, that that can be
a police officer says leave now and you leave,
but too slowly and the officers too slowly in the
opinion of the officer. And then the officer says
you're not obeying a lawful order, interfering
with law enforcement. These can be B.S. charges or
they can be legitimate in all of these three 286,
I believe, charges. The only court documents that
even reference and TFA are one case in Boston
where there was suspected and TFA activity that
was being investigated. That's certainly not
definitive. That's the one reference. And of
course, in the midst of this, there are plenty
of instances of right wing militia and far right
extremists who have been arrested. Two Missouri
militia members, three boogaloo movement members.
That's another right wing group and so on. So we
have a report now, an investigation, which tells
us what we already suspected. But the right either
doesn't understand or won't accept the other
obvious issue with saying a person is part of
an TIFA, as we've talked about before, is that
NTFS not an organization. It's more an ideology.
Most mostly it's just benignly being antifascist.
Now, even I as someone who has said I'm against
many of the tactics that some operating under the
name A. for the banner of anti for sometimes use,
I am against fascism, but I'm not part of any
organization. And there really is no organization,
which is part of the double edged sword where
you can accuse anyone of being part of an
organization that isn't really an organization.
It's like saying I'm a member of white nationalism
as an example. Well. OK. That's really an
ideology. There are groups that are heavily
white nationalist in nature, like the KKK. But
being a a member of white nationalism makes about
as much sense as being a member of an TIFA. The
other really important element to think about is
whether or not Antifa is a group or an extremist
group. It's actually irrelevant to the findings.
The people from the left who are in the streets
protesting are generally not violent, and unlike
the right, they've not been radicalized by some
monolithic right wing media apparatus or by Trump
or by Q and on. They're just normal people asking
for change and. That is a totally separate issue
from whether and TFA is or isn't an organization.
Almost everybody participating in these protests
has nothing to do whatsoever with the ideology
nor with the with with the organization. So
if you're surprised, let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,